a person brad geddes is here he's an
expert in the topic and he's going to be
sharing with us ways that you can
future-proof your job in the area of AI
and machine learning now in this webinar
we're going to talk about the impact of
machine learning on internet marketing
strategies and the job market
what machine can cannot do and how to
future-proof your job roles and the
structure your career in this new domain
where you're sharing it with machines so
just doing a little bit of housekeeping
here since all attendees are muted by
default if you want to ask a question at
the host or of the panelists first click
on the chat icon in the upper right
corner of the WebEx meeting center there
and a chat window will then appear in
the lower right and from the drop-down
make sure that you select the
participant to address your message -
and for that make sure you select a host
and presenter because in case Brad can't
see your question directly we'll be able
to do recognize it and forward it on to
him and then finally in the chat box you
can type your question or your comment
and then make sure you click the send
button just a reminder that in addition
to the chat function in WebEx you can
join us for a live chat on Twitter by
following us and tagging at simple learn
in your questions you can also joining
us join us on YouTube live just type
simply learn into the search bar on
YouTube and be sure to subscribe to
receive alerts for all upcoming YouTube
videos so now it's my pleasure to
introduce you to brad geddes
brad is the author of advanced google
adwords the co-founder of ad alysus and
automatic ad testing and PPC
recommendation platform brad frequently
writes columns for search engine land
and co moderates the adwords forum on
webmaster world he's also he noted and
spoken to more than 85 conferences and
led more than 80 AdWords seminars plus
he's a course advisor for the digital
marketing curriculum here at simply
learn so Brad thank you very much for
joining us for this really exciting
topic
excellent thank you Dan and just a check
can you hear me okay you're coming in
great alright perfect so so welcome
everybody so we're gonna walk through
today rate is about man versus machine
and how jobs are gonna get lost or in
more cases transform and then we'll look
at how automation affects different job
types I'm about prior knowledge which is
sort of some interesting studies we're
gonna dig into and the evolution BBC
jobs and then finally what are good ways
sort of future-proof in at your career
and so a lot of times people are sort of
afraid of automation right and it's not
that they like automation for the
personal uses they're afraid of
automation because it might cost them
their job and this is really not true
and in many many cases it transforms
them you know Dalat did a study this is
the UK job market and found that you
know over the course of time 800,000
low-skilled jobs were looted because
they are an automation right so that
sounds like a lot 800,000 lost jobs but
in reality because manufacturing costs
drop mining costs drop right what
happens is now there's actually more
money in the company and so this lost
800,000 jobs actually transformed into
3.5 million new jobs and those jobs paid
$13,000 a year more a huge difference so
if we sort of put this in a very
concrete example you know back in the
1970s was the invitation of the the ATM
the automated teller machine and so bank
tellers were afraid that they were all
gonna lose our jobs I mean if you could
just walk up to machine get out some
cash deposit your money not drink
banking hours but 24/7 365 a year why
would they have a job right and so as
ATM started being spread out more and
more they created jobs now that seems
sort of counterproductive
but the reason why is the average Bank
most of them were downtown locations
require 21 tellers right so the huge
overhead count now what happened then it
is ATMs rolled out and branches dropped
to 13 tellers okay so now there's
actually more money flowing the company
but it also meant it was cheaper to
operate any one branch and so then what
happened is where as a bigger
deregulation happen it makes the same
time but consumers demanded better
access to their local branches and so
suddenly we had all these micro banks
were popping up and it wasn't you had to
go downtown anymore to go to a bank you
could have one in your neighborhood and
so because of this access right there
more banks came more bank teller jobs
were created now the difference though
was her jobs changed before a thing
tellers job was mostly take deposits and
give cash back
all right the machine can do if the ATM
can do that so the job changed from
information processing right to
intelligence based so now your bank
teller was more educated on what if you
want to open a new checking account of
five types what's best for you if you
want to buy a new house we have all
these mortgage things and so this is
this an important point right change
from information to intelligence and
we're gonna come back to this point in
my calf an hour or so so when we
specifically look right at the at the
PPC arena so machine learning was
invented in the 1950s incredibly
expensive processing so it existed and
if you had a Cray computer or network of
craze you could run a little bit but it
was too expensive and too slow for
anyone to care it really existed and so
in 1998 my first paid search account now
number one I actually couldn't open it
online I did call someone to open it
there were no tools everything was
manual and keyword research was called
guesswork right there were no tools for
keyword research even and and then but
2001 so we're talking three years into
it go to goats host launches now go
toast is the very first bid management
solution what happened is there are
about eight rules you can employ such as
bit above a competitor bid to this
position set this bit number and
initially you could do it six times a
day then overture go to an overture API
got better it became twelve later become
twenty four times at in flying forty
eight now
problem is there was one tool every
large company use the same tool and so
whenever that times are updated off and
you could actually update bids we used
to do war sessions where we'd sit down
we'd pick our twenty top keywords we'd
refresh the page for 24 hours straight
on these keywords to map out when
everyone changed their bids and then
we'd sit there and say okay so they
changed their bids on the on the hour
mark we're gonna change them on the five
minutes after the hour mark so our last
bid set it was automated with the whole
lot of manual humans to it alright 2002
average launches so AdWords launched but
it was still all manual but later that
year he frontier launched now he
frontier was the first intelligent
bidding system which is was acquired by
Adobe they're not part of the Adobe
suite so then we think about oh four oh
eight
it wasn't about automation it was the
rise of the resellers your rh donnelly
decks media super pages thompson that
were managing ten top you know eighty
thousand PPC accounts this was about
school it was about scale when you're
scaling the things about organization
not automation marin launched a no six
cien brush didn't launch till 2008 I
think everyone knows semrush they're
only 10 years old
now 2010 big change happened Google
launched CPA bidding an automated bid
system run by AI that anyone access to
you know what in 2010 it was terrible it
was an awful awful system that raise
your CPAs and lowered your conversions
over doing it manually because it didn't
have any data yet
right when machine learning launches and
you use it you're actually the guinea
pig to give the machine learning of data
so it can make intelligent decisions but
we started getting more automation where
in life became about ads in margins met
2010's big shift happen called deep
learning
now deep learning is sort of a subset of
the AI arena which allows computers to
Processing's much much faster now to
give you an example right in the
computing store we have what's called
Moore's Law so Moore's law states that
computing power doubles right every
couple of years so if we apply this to
the automotive industry first car model
a and two and 1908 went 11 miles an hour
11 if we applied Moore's law to the
automotive industry the average car
would go over a billion miles an hour
and of course cars don't go a billion
miles an hour but that's how much
computing powers actually increased
right when we need to doubling to 4 8 16
32 64 128 256 right numbers get very big
very quickly and so machine learning
because of deep learning rate makes
machine learning feasible for a lot of
other technology and so we think about
this year biddings mostly automated that
used to be someone's job it's mostly
automated right machines are terrible at
ads right now we'll talk about this
local more in machine learning phase
right now
as much as it gets it right and part of
that student this concept of prior
knowledge will touch on a little bit so
when we look and say okay well what are
the actual jobs in paid search okay
under sales we have direct sales they
talk to customers they open an account
they land new clients for you and we
have business development right using
more large-scale enterprises
integrations we have market research and
then analyze the markets the competition
we need to devise strategies based upon
market competition and our abilities all
right we have analytics reporting giving
their clients or your boss or a monthly
report month over month over months and
then there's sort of a more concept of
data storytelling and then within an
account directly or we have writing
bidding and strategy again so we want to
do is say let's break these down and
let's look at how susceptible they are
two sort of computers taking over that
aspect right of a paid search account so
some of this data comes from is this
fantastic white paper done by Oxford
University that looks at the future of
employment right how susceptible are
jobs - right computer's taking over and
so there's sort of a front sight at war
over sick my job which actually
digitized the white papers when I kind
of start looking at the marketplace so
for example we look at sales rolls well
sales rolls are predicted to a declining
growth and 54 percent of their jobs or
may lost to automation does this mean
sales agents are in trouble yes for many
many good reasons right so here's sales
in paid search 1998 you had to call
somebody on the phone alright that sales
job gone right as soon as go to what
launched an online signup system right
no one's ever open an average account by
calling
Google and saying hey I want to open up
an AdWords account its online its
automated right by 2002 that was an
AdWords initial which is the CPM system
before the current AdWords rolled out
you had to do an insertion order so if
you've never dealt insertion orders
thank your lucky stars you had to submit
paperwork or faxes back and forth that
said here's the client here's the budget
here's the account number
I had an employee in 2005 their entire
job was to send and receive and
double-check 40,000 insertion orders
let's say a horrible job right that job
should be automated because no one needs
all that manual back and forth any
longer so yet these days lot of sales
jobs are automated you think of signing
up for base camp
Trello right any any task management
system is sauna
you didn't call them right 20 years ago
I said to call so I'm gonna make
something like that it's that it's on
one signup however business development
is different right business development
says here's what we offer here's what
you need how do we make these two things
work together right it's not purely a
sales role and so that's very much
immune to a lot of the the jut the
computers taking over but what would you
rather do call someone up to open up a
simple account or just do it yourself in
30 seconds whatever wants to do it
themselves we don't we don't need a lot
of this anymore now when it comes to
account managers people who are doing
the day-to-day work inside and Abers
account these aren't a direct
correlation because these are just
overall advertising and promotions
managers very very few these jobs are
actually gonna go away it'll transform
which we'll talk about more when you
think about the planning the directing
and the coordinating if advertiser
programs right that is
well saying our TV flight Lancet
launches on this day and our email
message says this and here's the type of
stuff you want to coordinate to our PPC
campaign a computer can't do that it'll
tell you when your flight schedule is it
can tell you that when your TV
commercials rained your paid search went
up 8% right it can't plan it but it can
give you the numbers afterwards and so
your pure day to day job is gonna be
fairly fairly robot proof however
however parts of that job will be
automated which we're getting to along
with statistics we say well why are
these jobs so secure it's because people
are irrational right computers are not
so this was a study that was done and
and it was it was a brand based study
initially out of MIT labs and so they
use agrippa monkeys and they had three
food dispensers now every food dispenser
gave you the exact same amount of food
so on the three dispensers they put a
picture of a brand logo and then a one
of them a dominant monkey another one a
subordinate and the third one is a
prenup or actually known as a sexy
monkey and so they they had these food
dispensers the sexy monkey of the Purina
was by far the most used food dispensary
even if the other two had no lines to
them monkeys would wait to get food from
that one the dominant was a second one
and then the subordinate now a computer
says well that's the shortest line why
would I wait to get the exact same
amount of food or a computer would make
a logical course the monkeys didn't then
they removed the picture the monkey and
left the brand next to it and they could
move these orders around right it wasn't
always the exact same spot the brand
next to sexy monkey got the most usage
even after the picture was removed all
right brand Association
and so this is why marketing is so
important and as humans associate
emotions and empathy to a brand a
computer says these three buttons give
me the same thing this one gives it to
me quicker I should use that one right
completely different decision-making
processes so we think about market
research market research 61% of jobs
probably going to go away now that's a
huge number right so we think about this
though they're going away from a market
research standpoint what will be left is
a lot of the testing and strategic
analysis of that research so to give you
an example if we put up there we this is
actual data or you put up two ads one
was 10% off one was free shipping the
average savings 10% off was $19.50 the
average savings from free shipping is
523 R and this was this was mostly aimed
at people who are 40-plus people don't
do math they say oh free free is good
let me click on free and buy from free
now if they chose 10% off they'd say $14
more right they're making the bad choice
from a financial standpoint but it was
by far more used now funny if we look at
the group that that's the younger group
that's usually 18 to about 34 they
prefer 10% off
even if 10% off is more expensive you're
buying a couch you probably want free
shipping on a couch not 10% off that's a
pretty hefty shipping fee right and so
even as we look at it was actually a
split right now by age ranges free
shipping versus 10% off both groups have
a preference neither one does the math
and so this is again why he won't
so illogical these are the kind of
market research questions that you need
to come up with to say how do that what
actually does best for us now what the
consumer said shoes because they're
gonna choose irrationally but we look at
market research it's become so much
seizure because the tools that exist
these days now SEMRush
spyfu eyes Minaj what runs we're similar
web moat right so access to competitive
data the very easy right once upon a
time you wanted to do competitive
research that meant getting a bunch of
IP addresses to anonymize the IPS across
different locations a human doing a
search or you know a bot doing a search
screenshotting what was there comparing
that screenshot to a previous screen
shot he was actually different if it is
different time stamping when it's
different putting it down in a chart so
the human could then start to look at
okay these that's really not different
it's you just change the word that
didn't really mean anything there's the
difference once so now we can plot out
how often they change ads how often
their messages go no one wanted that job
right it was a net it was necessary but
not when some rush and you know ice
Manoj and boat can automate that part
right now the human comes in and says
okay give my report okay this advertiser
is changing their ads every 14 days in
fact it's so like clockwork we can plan
out we need to look at this next here's
what they're running right now here's
our offer there's the difference that's
what we need to think about right and so
didn't get rid of some of these jobs it
transformed them to being interpreters
of the data and then they could be more
on the strategic side another important
word we're going to come back to a few
times and so it's not that the tools are
good all the tools are great do they
take some jobs yes did they make
the end result better though as
definitely right if someone was sick one
day you your screenshots you missed your
data now it's there right so they're
automating that the low quality horrible
jobs to make humans use their brainpower
more now analytics shows a clearer
picture there's three analytics types
involved in paid search one reporting
right so a statistical assistant is
someone who compiles and computes data
according to sort of predisposed models
that's reporting you know what this is a
part of paid search that not enough
people have automated you do the same
thing the first week of every month you
shouldn't be doing it Google Data studio
ninja cat a quiz EO they can all
automated right so again a lot of that
shouldn't be happening anyway now do you
need some people around who can go and
you ask some specific questions hey we
want to know what our trend on mobile
conversion rates is once we launch that
the new PageSpeed updates to make the
site faster did it affect us okay
that's useful right cuz you're asking a
question you need someone to go in and
grab that data great now our next step
in in statistics are write develop or
apply mathematical or statistical theory
in methods so collect organize and
TripIt surmise data all right so this
job is not just the collection right
it's the interpretation so we often hear
data storytelling it's a good word right
before we would give clients
here's your 50 pages of PDF and Excel
files and they would look at it and
they'd want to call the first couple
months they dealt with you then they
stopped because it was just the same
sort of data dump that had no meaning to
it
they really want is what does this mean
to me I I know something's happening all
right I can see all this data on these
calls in these conversions in this cost
per click and this Quality Score the CTR
but what does that mean great so that is
going to be a job that increases right
data storytelling and not giving someone
all the data but telling them what they
need to know how things are changing
based upon all that sort of data dump
analysis done which robust consumed to
some of it right to make it useful
information now the safest jobs people
who actually write the formulas create
the algorithms double-check the
algorithms just as important right so
your your conversion scientists right
those who are are really getting deep
deep into the psychology of how users
behave plus the data itself creating
models that's a very safe job because it
involves not just math in some cases
right conversion science where it
involves human psychology applied with
math and so we sort of look at these
jobs against each other right
statisticians going oh our stat
assistants going away their job role
follow pre-established out of routines
reporting bidding great that should be
that should be automated right there
following pre-established routines why
should a human do the same thing over
and over again right we think of
automation we think if I have to do it
by hand once fine if I have suited up by
hand twice I need to think is this give
me the exact same every time if yes you
know what no one should be doing it the
third time it should be automated right
that jobs can go away statisticians
understand data data storytelling
develop collect and organize useful
information some will be lost a lot will
be kept right formula and apply models
creating and auditing the machine that's
a job that no one's talking about much
which is gonna become more important
right now how do you order the machine
you turn on Google CPA bidding and you
hope it does well you try to look at the
data see ok it's doing well on desktops
but not on mobile so we if we want to
use it we need to make a desktop
campaign and a mobile campaign bid
manually and mobile and automating of
desktop right it's that thought process
of when it's working is it working
everywhere if it's not working
everywhere how do you split it off or is
it worth putting off right to make it
work everywhere so next we have writers
right so narrow Sciences a company who
automates articles full computer
automated in 2015 they were up more than
1 billion articles so from writers
standpoint machines wrote a billion from
one company that sounds terrible
let me think about it the articles are
writing is based on structured data box
scores quarterly reports when you go to
Yahoo Finance and your clients think
through you know Google Yahoo's
whoever's corley reports probably
written by a machine because it's
structured data that just needs some
context around it right so yeah those
are gonna go away but what computers
can't do is originate new ideas right so
computers they're get up modifying your
ideas there are they're good a
statistical significance they're good at
finding variations hey this additive
miss adage to mean the same thing rather
created that new ideas live with humans
and so if you're a creative copywriter
your job is in really really good shape
all right because this is originally
prepare written material scripts of
stories ads that's a human idea because
that involves empathy and involves with
connecting with a human one irrational
being connecting with yet another
irrational being right if it was
irrational connecting to not completely
rational like a computer we may have a
disconnect computers can probably write
for computers but they can't write for
humans now humans have to automate the
machines and this is why a lot of times
we see machine learning our first step
is to say well let's see this is really
any good or not because machine learning
doesn't always work you know Google
launched what they they love the word
smart right so they want smart display
campaigns so we went okay it's something
new let's try and see what happens now
this particular counter should have
stats in a second they run about a
twelve percent conversion rate on search
they run about an eight percent
conversion rate on display not including
their marketing which is even higher our
smart display campaign was twenty
thousand clicks and zero conversions now
if you're a human you would look like we
had to try to be that bad do you get
20,000 search clicks you probably get a
conversion rate that's the intent is
there I think I've seen 12 or 13
different display a smart display
campaigns all but one look like this ten
thousand clicks twenty thousand clicks
three thousand clicks conversions zero
one very low rate so humans have to
audit because what the early adopters
are doing is they're paying for the
machines to get enough data to figure
how to eventually make good decisions
now the difference here is humans have
what we call prior knowledge
so this is a 1980s video game and so
this could think of this is you know
Mario what not and so this this this is
out of MIT as well and so they um they
made this game and they put on
Mechanical Turk and said all right if
you finish this game they give me like a
quarter or something they then took the
23 best machine learning algorithms and
gave them the game now that the trick to
the first iteration was you only got a
reward which would be like a conversion
if you finished you don't get a reward
for making a correct move
you only get one if you finish a level
so what happened right humans took them
less than one minute to win the game
about 3,000 keystrokes only one machine
learning algorithm even finished the
game that particular algorithm took four
million keyboard actions which is
equivalent to playing it for 37 hours
straight
human one minute best algorithm 37 hours
so then my thing is you can look at this
right you're a human your prior
knowledge of video games so you can look
and say okay well I have to jump down
there I probably have to jump over the
fire I can climb up the ladders so you
can glance at this and you have an idea
right of how this works so so well let's
remove some prior knowledge ah let's
make it textures so some of those
textures happen to be ladders others are
fire so forth
now the second game here took humans who
bother to finish at five minutes I'm
sorry 20 minutes many gave up ahead to
increase Mechanical Turk payout rate to
a couple dollars to get people to finish
okay so we we annoyed humans but humans
are still finishing in 20 minutes
computers best one
took 37 hours all right
so we have a problem right even with
this humans are getting better now the
game was then modified to give more
rewards for completing an action so you
complete a level right not a hunt higher
not the game a level ah computers had
more awards most of the algorithms not
all of them could finish it all you get
a successful you get a notation a
successful award for doing a correct
action boom now computers faster than
humans huge difference with very low
data points machine learning can't
figure out how to play something humans
do in less than one minute right so in
thinking what does this mean to
marketing if I showed you these ads
whoops if I showed you these ads and I
said it's April the screenshot was taken
like three weeks ago it's April
do you think these ads should be running
every one of you should say well no
those are terrible
in fact some said 2013 on them which I
couldn't believe they were 2013 I'm
still running now a computer says well
these ads were created great November
21st and from November 21st until
December 20th they did really leather a
lot of searches there were a lot of
clicks like we had great data so the
machine decides right this is the best
out of your ad group now sometimes
machines don't test their own
assumptions they made a rule can they go
back and look at it secondly even if
they can what they need to say we need
enough data to change our minds problem
is search long for black party as a
course has dropped significantly because
it's 2018
and so we can't get if data to figure
out it needs to stop these so we think
about dramatic changes doing something
on a hunch
humans way way better than a computer so
computer doesn't have a hunch right that
I'd say that's a human human goes ban
ads let me change this my computer goes
huh okay these have dropped let me make
2017 2018 hmm that that didn't work let
me see what if we do white Friday deals
that might actually works it'll be
different for a little bit and then
it'll drop again because the pages are
broken or something else and computers
that note it completely changed the
message right so we think about
something as simple as ads computer can
make variations of current my Google
even oo has disability now with their ad
suggestions when they can determine a
test is taking place you got two ads in
that group or you're using this pattern
across 2000 ads and this other pattern
across 2200 ads I can detect there's a
pattern
I can Annika create an ad test based on
that pattern that's being used across
the accounts you can do that computers
come on statistical significance right
they can say hey we know you're running
an ad test in 2000 a groups and that you
have a thousand winners human is not
necessary for that step in fact they can
even pause it on your behalf right no
human no human necessary can be a
completely automate that what a computer
can't do is say this is what you should
test next that's the human part that's
the originating new ideas creativity so
so when we stack up computers versus
humans creativity humans strategy humans
storytelling humans right humans are
good at connecting and telling stories
to other humans quick market changes
humans right computers enough data to
know the market is changing I remember
city
sitting home one night and I saw TV
commercial come on
he was the first time accident
forgiveness was mentioned on a TV
commercial and I went wow
and and I reached for I can make that
computer then because I don't think I
had a cell phone that point how much I
remember and to send one of our
insurance clients us off before I got
hit but the client had actually already
emailed to me that we need to think
about this and how to respond right so
the commercial had just aired there was
no data yet the humans already realized
that was a game-changing moment in the
insurance industry and we needed to
figure out a story right then on the
spot right a computer has to say okay
your metrics are going down now
something happens right
adding machine humans empathy empathy
computers will never have empathy and
but the humans worst problem right the
weakness of a human it's time and speedy
calculation right now we think about a
computer ok they're better at math and
human than humans are humans make fret
finger things make mistakes move a
decimal point Peter's a way better at
math which means they're better at
bidding it means they're better at cisco
significance means are better in putting
repeatable data such as reporting now
where it's questionable right
conversations from human driven inputs
chat box is sort of like this
interesting hybrid world where the
humans are giving it conversations it
could be help files or something the
computers are having the conversations
with humans so it's actually human to
computer assisted conversations as
opposed to normally it's computer to
human assist it's actually inverse in
that case and but they're their worst
problem is when the data changes it
doesn't know to change its assumptions
and so a good example this is you
probably have all had PBC accounts
and you turned on the optimized feature
right so the best performing ads most
often and you start looking here in my
tricks and you know one in five at
groups your worst performer shows the
most all right and you look and say well
if I can see this with my eyes how can I
compete or not see it cuz early on a
lifespan it decided what was best and
that might have not been enough
information it could be that it had
moved on to something else to think
about right and so it doesn't always
correct itself and optimize versus
rotate is probably the setting in
AdWords that you can clearly see this
right more than any other setting in the
system but better another question ask
yourself is can you even automate it
alright so we think about automation we
say is a process repeatable and
consistent all right
no can you make it repeatable no you
can't automate it so then you could
automate alerts right so okay the
answers say are more than any person the
trick useful if yes great you could
automate alerts can I'm at the action
always be careful automating alerts I
mean target when they had their massive
data breach
what a year and a half ago or something
they had all kinds of alerts to as a
data breach but it was like 1% of their
four million daily alerts they never
noticed them right sort of sort of
difference so then you have to say okay
what processor people consistent we're
happy with our suggestions so then are
we happy with everything all right no
well then we may just you know automate
some alerts have everything yes so they
can automate it right so that's the
thing with automation is we have to be
happy with all the outputs the Machine
puts in and just some some quotes to
leave you with Rob Norman was the the
CEO of group and North America which is
the the largest you know ad buyer
probably in the world that started maybe
PNG and and you know he
said that there's no need to fear the
work marketers do is coming more
important because it's more critical now
in an AI powered world when people talk
about to their their their computer hey
give me this that they mentioned your
brand right and so you know empathy
right and being human is essential and
so we went from working with information
given to us right thirty years ago we
were information workers the machines
bid as a processing all right show us
decade right become we've become
intelligence workers now he's saying
it's time to change again right in the
new age of assistance we need to be
imagination workers right creativity
strategy because at the heart of
succeeding right as an imagination where
today is cultivating a deep desire to
help people navigate the daily lives and
tasks so his advice is to focus on
bringing a new level of imagination
creativity right to how you serve so
stay focused on consumer right ride the
wave the unknown take some rest
always child isatis quo and he's like
you normally evolve in this world you're
thriving it if you're a creativity and
strategy person so when we we kind of
recap here is a couple very important
points computers will transform jobs not
take them now prior knowledge right
really really useful you have to have it
though so we think of prior knowledge
and paid search where's that means you
actually have to know how all these
pieces fit together because you can't
audit a machine if you don't know how
it's supposed to work without the
machine right
very important point and so as we give
machines tasks to take where we always
have to check the machine
question is who's gonna be there who
actually knows what's happening so be
able to to check the machine we citizen
some industries right now were it was
automated fifty years ago and people
don't know how to how to completely
check stuff and so you know humans can
change directions dramatically quickly
and on a hunch I computers need data
so that's interpreting competitive
research humans are logical humans have
empathy visitor programmed right humans
are gonna be your writers they're gonna
be those who influence what advertising
is influencing someone to take action
right so computers you know they are
gonna take your job if you just do
reporting you just do data entry you
just do some bidding your job is gone
right if you are thinking here's what
we're doing here's the new as you want
to run here's how we want to compare
ourselves to this competitor here's a
new strategy we should employ when we we
sync up our email and our marketing
lists you're in great shape because
humans are going to retain creativity
strategy and the audit of the machine if
you want to keep joining us will be here
June twenty first for how to use PPC
tools our productivity and then in July
looking at how some big brands do their
ad testing and I will turn it back over
to Dan to see what kind of questions and
thoughts we have today great well thank
you Brad and it's very reassuring that
on digital marketing we won't be
completely replaced by the digital and
the empathy is it is a big part of that
I have a couple of questions here and
one of it is one of these is what sorts
of AI tools are available to automate
like rather than rather than worrying
about AI taking over but how can we
actually use AI ourselves are there any
ways to automate our PPC work already
like with AdWords scripts I'm guessing
or bad word scripts you have the API a
lot of this similar lists CPA bidding
robust bidding right there are actually
machine learning that is there for you
just you don't have to know how to do it
right it's
in plays you take advantage of end
market audiences
google has machine learning code
available for everyone to try to run
stuff through they've got a predictive
analytics code that you can put in some
some inputs and it'll say here's what we
predict will happen and so Google's got
a few resources now that you can
leverage to see how it works the the
thing that I think people miss at times
is that you have to ask it a specific
question or you have to tell it what
you're trying to accomplish and so you
can't just say here's my query data tell
me what to do right you gotta say here's
my query data and here are what I want
to know is how many queries I should get
that in long term right this should be a
negative keyword and so a basic filter
in many cases can do that in fact we we
took one of the algorithms and we we fed
in a large advertisers query data to ask
the the machine right at how many clicks
are we certain that the long-term
viability word is gonna spend more than
it makes and the Machine came back for
that particular account right everyone's
different and it was a hundred and
twenty nine clicks this account already
had a filter in place that said at a
hundred fifty clicks no conversions make
a negative keyword so a human prior
knowledge in some cases is actually as
good but that's so always be careful of
that but asking some simple ones that
you know how you would do it first and
see the difference but Google's got some
good resources already great yeah well
that's it that's an interesting thing to
keep in mind is - that actually learning
how to talk to the machine in the syntax
that will work best for you is a it's a
skill that's a that's useful as well the
another question is so the Google
announced that 20% of searches in the
Google mobile app in the US are done by
voice does that mean that we're on the
verge of not needing keywords anymore I
don't know this is really related
specifically
wait it falls and same thing so again
the search was done by voice but the
voice just translated the keyword that
then bought the results so that voice in
many in most cases voice search is just
keywords that are said as opposed to
typed which means more natural language
occurs which means you see a lot more
who what when why how you know words
right in question form but the keywords
are still the exact same it's just the
input type changed in some ways in tell
your answered by a voice and there's a
solo answer right or there's a screen
list device in most ways voice search
right now is the same as typing right
it's just the the keywords being used
are longer in length but there's still
just keywords right we have a question
from Pedro I actually cut a couple of
good questions so do you think a PPC
manager needs to master not only AdWords
but also Google Analytics and any other
analytics tool and understand better the
audience landscape or do they pretty
much is is the role of an isolated PPC
manager kind of going away that's a
great question so so I'm a so the way I
think of this right is if you are a
traffic driver which means you're a paid
search your email your organic social
your goals of drive traffic you need to
know the basics of analytics in
conversion because your conversion
optimization says make my traffic
convert better your analytics says tell
me the story you may not master them
both but you often want to be a
specialist and one and then have
knowledge maybe not super in-depth
because that GA can be its own code base
to get into you right it's actually
really tough when you get it's really
deep into it but have a base knowledge
of the others because that a lets you
set strategy across different systems
understand how you know PBC an organic
an email play together into analytics
and so while you not may not mash them
all having a solid you know background
education even it's the 101 201 level in
other disciplines helps you become a
much better you know paid SERPs in this
case I'm analysts great so let's say
Pedro does that answer your question for
you we're in the live chat right now
another question while we're waiting is
how can I get how can I get my online
store ready for matrices yes thank you
how can I get our online store ready for
a I like Google assistant voice driven
transactions there anything that we can
do on our side to to make it make it
easier to interact with AI knowing that
it's coming yes sort of playing with
chatbots
because in many ways right ai is just
accomplishing a task for somebody and so
we think about what tasks does someone
want to do well they want to be able to
comparison shop and you'll have a set a
group of users who want to be able to
check the items and see the detailed
detailed stats over the other group you
just want something quickly and and they
probably want to use more more chat BOTS
chat BOTS is an AI form of AI you can um
Microsoft although they got rid of their
one they've got a free chat bot system
they just killed the easy one to use to
put it all in Azure and it's a little
more difficult but but that can get you
started with sort of playing with here's
how our help files are structured here's
our content structured because the chat
bot needs structured content to work
from and so we can then look and say oh
here's what they asked is semantically
the same as this help file question
therefore I can give them that or what
they semantically asked is the same as
the description in this particular
product and this other one over here I
should recommend either one or both
depending on how you do your program on
your side so chat bots are a really good
sort of first iteration to play with
in in you know prepping consumers for AI
within how you you they shop from you
great okay well we have a one more
question and maybe we can make sense of
this the the question is what about AI
and click-fraud I'm not quite sure the
specifics of the question but I imagine
it's like what can we do to correct me
if I'm if I'm wrong Mary about if this
is what your question is about I'm
thinking like what come AI is out there
and how do we help protectors are PPC
from click from AI generated clickbait
or click fraud so in many ways that's
that's Google's problem as well because
you only see the information post click
and so you can see some of those
patterns where Google then develops AI
to counteract the AI that's trying to
click fraud so you can use you know
machine learning over your own data set
to qualify where you can throw a low
value traffic which may not be clicked
fraud but low value traffic and then you
can remove that from your own page which
account which could be a geography could
be certain IP ranges may or may not be
click fraud its but that would
essentially help you were to click fraud
while increasing your kind of fish the
same time but and in many ways that's
google's AI battle to fight and not
really the advertisers right yeah so
Mary saying that the specifics were how
can we tell if are there ways of
detecting if AI are is making click
fraud for us I mean is there anything a
week how can we as humans tell the
difference between legitimate if
something looks suspicious what's it
what's a good cue that we may be the
victim of this so it's it's mobile
phones made this much harder because so
like on a computer right you can you can
look and say if this particular session
clicks on a button but does not have
mouse movement
then it's probably a bot now could be a
screen reader from someone who's blind
right or low visually impaired so it's
not always that way but you know using
mass movements was a great way of
looking at that you can do browser
fingerprinting most browsers are
actually unique because there's a
different you know screen resolution in
browser plugins and and color palettes
and language and so forth so you can
start fingerprinting browser types again
a lot of work mobile phones are much
harder because there's not plugins and
there's not Sully mouse movement there's
a human scroll which doesn't always get
pushed back to the the your analytics
side so it's easier on computers and
phones by far to check for that but
things like mass MIMO detection is a
very simple one to implement and will
tell you know that someone was on a
computer and actually clicked three
buttons but never actually move their
mouse so if that's coming from a set of
IPS a country type you know that's
indication you want more on
investigation but does not always mean
click fraud great well that's that's
good advice too so we're about to wrap
up here if there's any last-minute
questions we can with time to ask maybe
one more but in the meantime if you have
other questions feel free to pop and ask
them on the YouTube video I sent
everyone a link to our YouTube video
check us out on simply learn just search
simply learn on YouTube and you'll see
you'll see this webinar and a bunch of
other recordings as well and you can
continue the conversation by asking us
right there.i you could also contact us
on twitter like at simply learn and
we'll get back to you too so I just want
to say thank you again Brad this was a
fun topic and a lot of people were
really engaged with us today my pleasure
and that just a reminder Doron instead
of course you can re-watch and we share
this webinar instantly right now in
YouTube
for all those who registered through
WebEx please keep an eye out for
follow-up email in a week or so with a
written wrap-up of this webinar that you
can share with your friends family
coworkers and colleagues and also the
video and more remember to follow brad
geddes on twitter at BG theory for more
information on PPC best practices and
more and if you have any other further
questions like I said they didn't get
addressed just feel free to tweet at us
or leave a Content comment on youtube
and for a full schedule of all upcoming
webinars and events please head over to
our Facebook page
just look for a simpler so thanks again
Brad and let's I look forward to to
fighting the robots with you in the near
future excellent thank you Dan okay
goodbye everyone
you